My overall point is that people like to
have a victim mindset especially
victimization I'm just saying he exists
okay that's it that's my point is that
we hear this victimized mindset right
now in order to give you a way to
navigate the world that justifies a lot
of your thoughts and beliefs we're
talking about race and you're like it's
giving misogyny no you
know you're calling out the
victimization of the race you feel the
vibrations of misogyny yeah
of your mentality your mentality is one
of your type of man that's what type of
man no sister they're just here trying
to make you look stupid that's what
their job is it's not that hard it's not
that [__] hard don't take it personal
they at least you just want to catch you
out
I'm trying to get to what she really
believes King Richard's trains me for
this all right what what are the
vibrations that I'm giving you that is
given misogynist why what did we say I'm
not being funny if what value do you see
and what what how do you value women do
you see the value of women like are you
I explained it five minutes ago you
didn't I said that I'm against feminism